Hello. This is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I'm Neil.
And I'm Rob.
Now, I'm sure most of us have interacted
with a chatbot.
These are bits of computer technology
that respond to text with text
or respond to your voice.
You ask it a question
and usually it comes up
with an answer.
Yes, it's almost like talking
to another human.
But of course, it's not.
It's just a clever piece
of technology.
It's becoming more sophisticated,
more advanced and complex,
but could they replace
real human interaction altogether?
We'll discuss that
more in a moment and find out if chatbots
really think for themselves. But first,
I have a question for you, Rob. The
first computer program that allowed
some kind of plausible conversation
between humans and machines
was invented in 1966.
But what was it called?
Was it a) Alexa.
b) Eliza, or c) Parry?
Well, it's not Alexa,
that's too new, so I'll guess
c) Parry.
I'll reveal the answer
at the end of the programme.
Now, the old chatbots of the 1960s and 70s
were quite basic.
But more recently, the technology is
able to predict the next word that is
likely to be used in a sentence and it
learns words and sentence structures.
It's clever stuff.
I've experienced using them
when talking to my bank
or when I have problems trying
to book a ticket on a website.
I no longer phone a human,
I speak to
a virtual assistant instead.
Probably the most well known chatbot
at the moment
is ChatGTP.
It is. The claim is
that it's able to answer
anything you ask it.
This includes writing
students' essays.
Now, this is something
that was discussed on the BBC
Radio 4 programme, Word of Mouth.
Emily M Bender,
Professor of Computational
Linguistics at the University
of Washington, explained
why it's dangerous to always trust
what a chatbot is telling us.
We tend to react to grammatical,
fluent, coherent seeming text
as authoritative and reliable
and valuable and
we need to be on guard against that
because what is coming out of ChatGTP
is none of that.
So, Professor Bender says that
well written text, that is coherent -
that means it's clear,
carefully considered and sensible -
makes us think what we are reading is
reliable and authoritative.
So it's respected, accurate
and important sounding.
Yes, chatbots might appear to write
in this way. But really,
they are just predicting one word after
another based on what they have learnt.
We should therefore be on guard - be careful
and alert about the accuracy
of what we are being told.
One concern is that chatbots - a form
of artificial intelligence - work
a bit like a human brain in the way
it can learn and process information.
They are able to learn from experience.
Something called deep learning.
A cognitive psychologist and computer
scientist called Geoffrey Hinton,
recently said he feared that chatbots
could soon overtake the level
of information that a human brain
holds. That is a bit scary isn't it?
But for now, chatbots can be useful
for practical information,
but sometimes
we start to believe they are human
and we interact with them
in a human like way.
This can make us believe them
even more.
Professor Emma Bender,
speaking on
the BBC's Word of Mouth
programme, explains
why we might feel like that.
I think what's going on there is,
the kinds of answers
you get depend on the questions
you put in, because it's doing likely
next word, likely next word.
And so, if as the human interacting
with this machine
and you start asking questions
about how do you feel, you know, chatbot?
And, what do you think of this?
What are your goals?
You can provoke it to say things
that sound like what a sentient
entity would say. We are really primed
to imagine a mind behind language
whenever we encounter language.
And so we really have to account for that when
we're making decisions about these.
So, although a chatbot might sound human,
we really just ask it
things to get a reaction.
We provoke it.
And it answers only with words
it has learned to use before.
Not because it has come up
with a clever answer,
but it does sound like a sentient
entity. Sentient describes a living
thing that experiences feelings. As
Professor Bender says we imagine
that when something speaks there is a mind
behind it. But sorry Neil,
they are not your friend.
They're just machines.
Yes, it's strange then
that we sometimes give chatbots names.
Alexa, Siri, and earlier
I asked you what the name was
for their first ever chatbot?
And I guessed it was Parry. Was I right?
You guessed wrong, I'm afraid.
Parry was an early form of chatbot
from 1972.
But the correct answer was Eliza.
It was considered to be the first
chatterbot, as it was called then,
and was developed by Joseph Weizenbaum
at Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
Fascinating stuff.
OK, now let's recap some
of the vocabulary
we highlighted in this programme,
starting with sophisticated,
which can describe technology that
is advanced and complex.
Something that is coherent, is clear
carefully considered and sensible.
Authoritative means respected
accurate and important sounding.
When you are on guard
you must be careful
and alert about something.
It could be the accuracy of what
you see or hear or just being aware
of the dangers around you.
To provoke means to do something
that causes a reaction from someone.
Sentient describes something
that experiences feelings.
So it's something
that is living. Once again
our six minutes are up. Goodbye.
Bye bye for now.